ZDF heute live herzlich willkommen
Trauer in der Ukraine heute genau ein
Jahr nach dem Russland das Land überfiel
wie hier in Butcher weinen sie um die
Toten hier haben die Einwohner besonders
unter der Besatzung gelitten in Kiew
gedenken Soldaten bei einer
Schweigeminute ihrer gefallenen
Kameraden Präsident selenski ehrt die
die bei den Kämpfen gestorben sind und
dank den Hinterbliebenen für ihre Opfer
und er erinnert an den Tag als die
Invasion begann
drei Tage hieß es würden wir aushalten
sie drohten uns in 72 Stunden zu
vernichten doch wir überlebten den
vierten Tag und danach auch den fünften
und heute überleben wir seit genau einem
Jahr und immer noch wissen wir jedes
weitere morgen ist es wert dafür zu
kämpfen
ja der Unverwundbarkeit am Ende steht
dass wir es ausgehalten haben wir wurden
nicht besiegt und wir werden alles dafür
tun dieses Jahr zu siegen
es ging heute darum vor allem die Moral
des Landes hochzuhalten die Kämpfe gehen
weiter vor allem im Osten der Ukraine
wie kann das enden wenn wir uns diese
Frage stellen dann lernen wir in diesen
Tagen Frieden ist nicht gleich Frieden
es gibt einen Frieden und es gibt einen
Unterschied ob er der Ukraine
aufgezwungen wird oder einen Frieden der
bedeutet dass die Ukraine ihre Freiheit
ihre Souveränität wieder erlangt was
kann also der Ukraine den Frieden
bringen den sie braucht und welche
Chancen auf Frieden gibt es derzeit
überhaupt das ist unser Thema heute wir
sind gespannt auf eure und ihre
Meinungen und Fragen dazu an die
eingeblendete E-Mail-Adresse oder gerne
in die Chats und auch mit Dingel habe
ich gerade schon gesehen fragt über
Youtube sind Fragen erlaubt und werden
diese mit Glück gestellt die Frage kann
ich ganz klar mit ja beantworten her mit
den Fragen und wir versuchen sie hier zu
stellen und zu beantworten
und zwar mit zwei Experten wir haben
eingeladen die friedensforscherinnen
Nicole deitelhoff und den
Militärhistoriker Markus
wir beginnen dort wo sich die Menschen
den Frieden am sehnlichsten wünschen und
zwar in der Ukraine selbst dort ist für
uns unsere Reporterin Katrin Eigendorf
in Kiew Katrin wie hast du diesen Tag
heute erlebt
ja ich habe diesen Tag heute angefangen
in haarkif im Osten der Ukraine wo die
Situation doch wesentlich angespannter
ist als hier in Kiel da war doch eine
große Angst davor zu spüren dass die
Stadt an diesem Tag massiv angegriffen
wird in den Dörfern im Norden der Stadt
hat es auch an dem Tag verschiedene
Angriffe gegeben aber insgesamt ist die
Situation relativ ruhig gewesen wir
haben uns dann auf den Weg gemacht nach
Kiel und als wir hier angekommen sind
hat sich doch schon an etwas anderes
Bild ergeben also man merkt schon dass
auch ein gewisser Riss durch das Land
geht hier in Kiel ist bei allem Schmerz
den die Menschen natürlich hier auch
erleben und bei aller Trauer das Leben
doch viel normaler als wir das im Osten
der Ukraine erleben dort finden in
vielen Teilen erbitterte Kämpfe statt
dort sind auch viele Dörfer und Städte
auch teilweise so weit zerstört dass die
Menschen dort gar nicht mehr richtig
leben können während man hier in Kiew
eben erlebt dass die Menschen heute auch
in den Cafés gesessen haben ja Kuchen
gegessen haben hier spazieren gegangen
sind also dieser Riss ist schon
beachtlich
Katrin welche Aussicht auf Frieden sieht
man denn derzeit in der Ukraine
im Moment sind die Aussichten auf
Frieden sehr sehr gering ich würde sagen
das Land steht im Moment an einem
Tiefpunkt was wir erleben sind
erbitterte und schwere Kämpfe ich habe
es gerade schon gesagt im Osten der
Ukraine um die Stadt bachmut spricht man
davon dass es die schlimmsten kämpfe
seit Beginn des Krieges sind wir sehen
das alle Versuche Russland irgendwie zu
Verhandlungen zu bewegen gescheitert
sind
dass der Krieg von Russland mit
unverminderter Härte so weitergeführt
wird sogar immer wieder eskaliert wird
es gibt im Moment überhaupt gar keine
Anzeichen dafür dass es hier zu einer
Annäherung kommen kann denn russland
will von seinem Anspruch die Ukraine zu
erobern die Regierung zu entmachten und
das Land zu besetzen nicht abweichen
Katrin ich gucke hier in die Chats da
gibt es viel Diskussionen schon darüber
was denn Frieden bedeutet das geht vor
allem in Richtung der Diskussion die
hier in Deutschland auch geführt wird
Alice Schwarzer und Frau Wagenknecht von
der Linkspartei haben ja da ein Manifest
veröffentlicht dass viele Unterstützer
auch bekommen hat darüber sprechen wir
später in der Sendung und an die
Userinnen und User die dazu Fragen haben
darauf werden wir später noch dezidiert
eingehen aber bleiben wir noch in der
Ukraine du hast die entsprechenden
Punkte gerade genannt was kannst du noch
mal wiederholen was ist für die Ukraine
zentral
nun für die Ukraine ist das zentral was
für jeden Staat zentrale ist dass sie
nämlich darauf pochen auf die
Souveränität ihres Landes und darauf
dass sie selber darüber entscheiden
welchen Weg ihr Land geht das ist ja
etwas was Russland ihnen nehmen will und
was Russland bezweifelt die Souveränität
und die territoriale Integrität der
Ukraine in dem es das Land angegriffen
hat besetzt hat und die Regierung hier
entmachten will und ihre Legitimität in
Frage stellt und da ähnelt diese
Position ja eigentlich auch dem wovon
worauf dieses Manifest basiert dass man
nämlich auch in Deutschland mit diesem
sogenannten friedensmanifest der Ukraine
ihre territoriale Integrität nehmen will
und auch die Entscheidung darüber welche
Zukunft das Land hier haben möchte also
die Ukraine sehen dass mit großem
Entsetzen was da was dafür Positionen
vertreten werden denn aus Sicht der
Ukraine
die Ukrainer sagen es kann keinen
Frieden ohne Gerechtigkeit geben ein
Frieden muss bedeuten dass Russland
sofort seine Truppen hier abzieht die
Kämpfe einstellt und die Souveränität
der Ukraine achtet das ist ja im Prinzip
auch Gegenstand der UN-Resolution
gewesen der sich ja im nur sechs Staaten
an der Seite Russlands entgegengestellt
haben also es geht um ein sehr
fundamentales Prinzip ja einer globalen
Weltordnung auch das Staaten in ihrer
territorialen Integrität und
Souveränität nicht angegriffen werden
dürfen darauf beharren die Ukraine
nun gibt es ja einen neuen eine neue
Friedensinitiative nennen wir das mal
heute von chinesischer Seite wie wird
denn das in der Ukraine selbst
aufgenommen
für die Ukraine ist China kein seriöser
Gesprächspartner wenn es darum geht hier
eine Friedensinitiative zu initiieren
denn China hat sich ja im Prinzip bei
dieser UN-Resolution die ich gerade
erwähnt habe enthalten China spielt in
den Augen der Ukraine hier ein doppeltes
Spiel in dem es auf der einen Seite ja
an der Seite Putins steht und sich immer
wieder als Partner auch Putins verhält
und auf der anderen Seite eben diesen
Friedensvertrag oder diesen Friedensplan
hier entwirft wenn man sich das mal
genau anguckt da muss man wirklich
fragen ja was sind denn die genauen
Voraussetzungen für einen Frieden aus
der Sicht der Ukraine kann Frieden nur
hergestellt werden wenn Russland hier
seine Truppen komplett von ukrainischem
Staatsgebiet abzieht und zwar in den
Grenzen von 1991 also auch von der Krim
und wenn Russland sofort alle Kämpfe
einstellt das ist ja eine Voraussetzung
die China gar nicht fordert von daher
ist es kein ähm kein Dokument auf dessen
Grundlage man sich hier wirklich näher
kommen kann
sagt Katrin Eigendorf in Kiew vielen
Dank für diese Einschätzungen aus der
Ukraine an diesem Jahrestag der Invasion
danke schön Katrin und damit begrüße ich
hier im Studio die beiden Experten die
ich gerade eingangs schon eingeführt
habe da sind sie die friedensforscherin
Professor Nicole deitelhoff sie leitet
das Leibniz-Institut hessische Stiftung
Friedens und Konfliktforschung in
Frankfurt am Main und ich begrüße den
militärökonom DR Markus Keup er ist
Dozent für Militär Ökonomie an der
Militärakademie der eidgenössischen
Technischen Hochschule Zürich schön dass
sie beide da sind und ich sehe wie
gesagt hier auch schon ganz viele Fragen
wir schauen auf diesen chinesischen
Friedensplan genauer mal zu beginnen wir
haben eine Grafik vorbereitet und haben
das Friedensplan mit Anführungszeichen
direkt versehen denn inwiefern das jetzt
ein Plan ist oder eine Initiative
darüber werden wir gleich sprechen
können also was genau ist das was China
da anbietet was China schon letzte Woche
bei der SIKO in München vorgestellt hat
Verhandlungen aufnehmen ist ein
zentraler Punkt dann geht es darum
Souveränität und territoriale Integrität
aller Länder waren das kann man so lesen
als richte sich das gegen Moskau
allerdings hat Tina ist ja bisher
vermieden den russischen Angriffskrieg
zu verurteilen und es ist auch nicht
ganz klar welche Grenzen hier gemeint
sind keine Militärblöcke bilden wie im
Kalten Krieg dass es auch ein Punkt das
ist hier formuliert als
Sicherheitsinteressen aller Länder
berücksichtigen dann klar keine
Atomwaffen und wirtschaftliche Folgen
begrenzen so weit also die wichtigsten
der 12 Punkte dieser Initiative Frau
deitelhoff wie ist ihre Einschätzung die
von Katrin Eugendorf haben wir gerade
schon gehört wie es ihre
ja man kann eigentlich nicht von einem
Friedensplan sprechen das Papier heißt
übrigens auch gar nicht Friedensplan
sondern Positionspapier das ist es auch
und es listet so ein bisschen auf was
China in den Vereinen vorangegangenen
Monaten immer wieder gesagt hat wir
hören also gar nichts Neues ich würde
als positives herauslesen dass China
noch einmal betont dass man es nicht
duldet das mit Nuklearwaffen gedroht
wird oder gar ein nuklear Krieg begonnen
wird das ist schön das ist das noch mal
bestärkt aber ansonsten finden sich ja
eigentlich keine Pläne also kein Prozess
wie man denn vom jetzigen Zustand indem
wir uns befinden
hinzufriedensverhandlung kommen könnte
Herr Dr Keup wie sehen Sie das
ich sehe das ganz ähnlich also wir haben
ja immer wieder chinesische
Staatsfunktionäre gesehen also nicht nur
heute sondern auch in den vergangenen
Monaten die immer wieder einen Satz
geäußert haben die Prinzipien der
un-karta sollten respektiert werden wenn
man das jetzt mal ernst nimmt das
Hauptprinzip der un-karte also das
wesentlichen völkerrechtlichen Werkes
das zwischen 45 und 47 geschaffen worden
ist die Grundlage unserer Welt der Welt
nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg die hat einen
zentralen Grundsatz nämlich das
Gewaltverbot also genauer gesagt das
Verbot des Angriffskrieges so und wenn
sich China jetzt hinstellt und sagt die
Prinzipien der un-karte sollen Beachtung
finden dann würde ich doch vorschlagen
dass man hier mit anfängt mit dem
Gewaltverbot wenn man das also wirklich
beachtet dann gibt es nur einen Weg
nämlich den vollständigen Rückzug
Russlands inklusive seiner Truppen
natürlich aus der Ukraine und die
Wiederherstellung der ukrainischen
Staatlichkeit in den Grenzen von 1991
erst dann ist die völkerrechtswidrige
Aggressionen wieder neutralisiert das
heißt also der Krieg beginnt nicht 22
obwohl wir jetzt den Jahrestag feiern
der Krieg beginnt 2014 mit der
völkerrechtswidrigen Invasion auf die
Krim und der sogenannten Annexion die
natürlich keine ist ja also diese
Gebiete in der Ukraine die sind nicht
annektiert von Russland wie man es
häufig in den Medien hört sie sind
völkerrechtswidrig besetzt und zwar nun
seit bald neun Jahren und darum geht es
eigentlich das heißt das würde ich doch
den chinesischen
Funktionären nahe liegen dass sie da
ihren Worten auch Taten folgen lassen
und die Russen dazu bewegen aus der
Ukraine abzuziehen und sofern sie das
nicht tun oder dazu nicht bereit sind
ist das eigentlich nur ein ein
politisches Manöver es ist eine
Zusammenfassung der der chinesischen
politischen Position aber es ist sicher
kein Frieden
da möchte ich gerne an der Stelle eine
Frage aus dem Chat weitergeben
vielleicht gerade weil sie es auch
angesprochen haben was die russischen
Truppen angeht an Sie Herr Kolb Markus W
fragt mich würde mal interessieren wie
wahrscheinlich es ist das Russland alle
seine Truppen abziehen würde ich glaube
da definitiv nicht dran schreibt der
User
also ich glaube im Moment auch noch
nicht daran dass Russland das freiwillig
machen würde dafür müsste ein
Katalysator hinzukommen und der ist in
zweierlei Hinsicht denkbar ähm das eine
was ich eher glaube ist dass die Ukraine
im Frühjahr zu einer begrenzten
Offensive übergehen wird und zwar vor
allem mit den westlichen panzersystemen
an denen die Ukraine derzeit ausgebildet
werden das wird vermutlich Ende März
Anfang April der Fall sein und dann wird
zumindest ein Teil der russischen Front
unter starkem Druck kommen das heißt
also dann wird Putin zum ersten Mal
sehen dass eine Niederlage oder
zumindest eine Spaltung der Front
militärisch möglich ist und dann könnte
er tatsächlich wenn er noch halbwegs
rational ist zu dem Schluss kommen okay
dieser Krieg ist nicht zu gewinnen und
je länger er dauert desto mehr neigt
sich die Waagschale auf die Seite der
Ukraine an das wäre eine Möglichkeit die
andere wäre dass er zunehmend in seinem
Regime ihnen politische Widerstände
bekommt also von anderen Playern die
sagen Wladimir lass mal gut sein weil so
gut läuft der Krieg nicht es sollten
jetzt vielleicht andere kommen hat das
ja schon versucht und es gibt im Moment
in Russland Bestrebungen von
verschiedenen Parteien die sagen wir
bauen uns jetzt unsere privat Armee auf
also wir haben nicht nur die Wagner von
Gregorian hat auch schon solche
Bemerkungen fallen lassen Gas kommt der
Konzern beginnt gerade mit dem Aufbau
einer eigenen Söldnertruppe das heißt
also wenn das passiert wenn wenn
Russland zunehmend solche Power
struggles bekommt dann müsste Putin
eigentlich seine Gewaltmittel die jetzt
in der Ukraine stehen zurückziehen nach
Russland und dort seine eigene Macht zu
sichern also da auch das könnte ein
Katalysator sein für einen Rückzug
ich denke Putin hat im Moment noch nicht
realisiert oder er will noch nicht
wirklich glauben wie schlecht die
militärische Lage für die Russen im
Moment ist vor allem an dem
Frontabschnitt zwischen krimina und
fulletta
auch ein Großteil der Medien betet so
ein bisschen die russische Propaganda
nach und sagt das Märchen von den
unendlichen russischen Reserven das ist
nicht so Russland verliert im Moment
sechs Kampfpanzer und sieben in refiding
pro Tag diese abnutzungsrate ist
schlichtweg nicht durchzuhalten
das klar werden hoffentlich und dann
wenn sie noch halbwegs rational sind
werden Sie möglicherweise sich
zurückziehen ansonsten werden sie
eingekesselt und letztlich vernichtet
soweit also die militärischen
Einschätzungen zu einer Chance auf
Frieden aus ihrer Sicht Herr Dr Kolb ähm
Frau deitelhoff hier kommt die Frage von
beach and Palms auch über Youtube warum
arbeiten nicht alle Länder an einem
Friedensplan die EU USA China Russland
und die Ukraine Präsident selenski hat
das ja selber heute auch auch mal
wiederholt er fordert einen Gipfel über
den Frieden aber natürlich hat er auch
seine Bedingungen warum gibt es nicht
eine solche gemeinsame Bemühung
also ich glaube zum einen gibt es
natürlich gemeinsame Bemühungen zum
einen unter den westlichen Staaten die
ja auch immer noch Gespräche mit dem
Kreml suchen um auszuloten ob es
überhaupt eine Öffnung auf russischer
Seite für Verhandlung gibt die größere
Problematik für eine globale Initiative
ist das nicht alle Seiten gleichermaßen
Interesse an einem Frieden haben und das
beginnt schon bei China das jetzt nicht
nur ein Friedensplan vorgelegt hat der
gar kein Friedensplan ist sondern das
natürlich auch davon profitiert dass im
momentan die USA stark gebunden sind in
der Ukraine und selber eben in der Zeit
sozusagen ihre eigenen Interessen im
südlichen chinesischen Meer im
Indopazifik und natürlich auch gegenüber
Taiwan durchsetzen können also von daher
und man profitiert nicht zuletzt sollte
man anders sagen von den billigen
Energieexperten die man jetzt aus
Russland haben kann also von daher ist
das Interesse nicht auf allen Seiten
gleich und das behindert auch eine
globale Friedensinitiative selenskys
Aufruf einen solchen Friedensgipfel zu
machen der soll genau das eigentlich
hervorbringen der soll die Staaten
nötigen nämlich ihre Interessen hier
offenzulegen und damit auch offenzulegen
wer ist denn wirklich für ein
Friedensplan zu haben und wer nicht
ich gucke hier in die Chats und sehe
dass viele sich auf das wagenfest der
Wagenknecht Manifest Berufen hier
schreibt jemand Memo morgen alle nach
Berlin zur Friedensdemo ich würde das
gerne zum Anlass nehmen um über diesen
Komplex zu sprechen weil das viele
Menschen hier in Deutschland umtreibt
schauen wir erstmal auf den Tag heute
den Jahrestag der Invasion haben viele
tausend Menschen genutzt um in
Deutschland ihre Solidarität mit der
Ukraine zu zeigen gerade in diesen
Minuten hier in Berlin passiert das wir
sehen ukrainische Flaggen in Berlin wir
sehen das Brandenburger Tor erleuchtet
in den Nationalfarben der Ukraine und es
gab heute auch eine Menschenkette von
Münster nach Osnabrück und 20.000
Menschen haben sich an dieser
friedenskette beteiligt Kommunen Vereine
Kirchengemeinde Kirchengemeinden und
Parteien hatten dazu aufgerufen also die
Sehnsucht nach Frieden ist groß und
jetzt reden wir erstmal darüber würde
ich vorschlagen denn ähm dieser Wunsch
nach Frieden der ist ja legitim jetzt
muss man gucken wer diesen Wunsch äußert
und mit welchen politischen Forderungen
und vielleicht auch fehl Einschätzungen
verknüpft aber erstmal dr Keup ist es ja
gut und richtig dass die Menschen auf
die Straße gehen und sagen wir möchten
dass das Töten aufhört dass die Kämpfer
aufhören
also ich möchte den Vertretern dieses
sogenannten manifestes für Frieden
zunächst einmal das sagen was Thomas
Mann 1941 schon gesagt hat sie reden von
Frieden und meinen Unterwerfung es macht
einen sehr großen Unterschied warum man
Frieden fordert und wie man diesen
Frieden haben will ein Frieden der die
russische Aggression belohnt und die
Ukraine in ihrer territorialen
Souveränität und Integrität beschneidet
ist kein Frieden es ist Belohnung der
russischen Aggression Belohnungen eines
Angriffskrieges und dann auf der anderen
Seite muss man auch ganz klar sagen die
Vertreterinnen dieses manifestes sind in
der Gesellschaft eine Minderheit auch
wenn Sie das Gegenteil behaupten ich mal
schauen Sie sie haben ja vom ZDF selber
das Politbarometer und wenn Sie diese
Umfragen anschauen dann werden Sie
feststellen dass ein Großteil der
Deutschen vor allem der westdeutschen
Bevölkerung hinter den Waffenlieferungen
und hinterm den solidaritätsmaßnahmen
für die Ukraine steht ich selber gehört
übrigens zu den Erstunterzeichnern einer
Petition und die heißt ganz einfach die
Ukraine jetzt aufgeben Fragezeichen
nicht in unserem Namen und die haben wir
heute fast 20.000 Menschen
unterschrieben ich denke man muss das in
diesem Kontext sehen es ist für mich
auch ein bisschen ein Medienphänomen das
so ein bisschen wie in der Pandemie eine
eine kleine aber sehr laute Minderheit
schreit und glaubt sie können damit die
öffentliche Debatte beherrschen aber dem
ist nicht so und ich denke es gibt eine
große Schweine Mehrheit wenn ich da kurz
einhaken darf es sind immerhin mehr als
600.000 Unterzeichner dieser Petition
und je nachdem welche Umfrage man sich
anguckt klar sie haben das
Politbarometer erwähnt aber es gibt auch
verschiedene andere Umfragen da ist die
Sehnsucht nach Frieden ganz ganz klar
wie auch immer motiviert die ist ganz
klar Frau Professor deitelhoff was ist
ihre Position dazu
also ich würde auch sagen natürlich gibt
es diese Sehnsucht nach Frieden und
ehrlich gesagt die Teile ich ja auch und
das Problem ist ist das glaube ich viele
Menschen nicht erkennen warum offen oder
so offenbar in der Politik nicht an
einem Friedensplan sie haben das eben ja
auch gefragt gearbeitet wird und
vielleicht sollte man sich das noch mal
klar machen
dass Manifest dass wir hier vor uns
haben das jetzt sofort
friedensverhandlung fordert ein Ende der
Waffenlieferung ein Ende der Sanktion
friedensverhandlung jetzt was ist nicht
erkennt oder was ist vielleicht nicht
durch argumentiert ist wenn wir jetzt
unsere militärische Unterstützung für
die Ukraine einstellen würden wenn wir
jetzt die Sanktion aufheben würden dann
würde es darauf hinauslaufen dass die
Ukraine in ein vielleicht zwei
vielleicht drei Monaten unterlegen sein
wird also militärisch diesen Krieg
verlieren wird und wir haben keinerlei
Anzeichen dafür dass es dann ein Anreiz
für die Russische Föderation geben würde
in faire Verhandlungen mit der Ukraine
einzusteigen sondern viel mehr müssen
wir damit rechnen dass sie dann ihre
Ziele schlicht und einfach umsetzen wird
das heißt dass die unabhängige Ukraine
dann verloren sein wird das ist der
Punkt warum sich so viele Expertinnen
und Experten aber auch andere Menschen
gegen dieses Manifest richten wir
brauchen einen Zustand wir müssen einen
Zustand erreichen in diesem Konflikt in
dem es plausibel wird das auch die
russische Seite bereit ist tatsächlich
offen in Verhandlung einzusteigen und da
sind wir gegenwärtig noch nicht und da
würde ich das Problem sehen es geht
nicht darum dass man die territoriale
Integrität der Ukraine nicht mal mehr
verhandeln darf natürlich kann man das
wir reden über einen Krieg in einem
Krieg geht es darum irgendwie überhaupt
zu neuen Kompromissen zu kommen und es
gibt ja Möglichkeiten über die kann man
natürlich reden nur wir sind noch gar
nicht in dem Stadium wo wir überhaupt
Behandlung anfangen könnten und da
müssen wir erstmal hinkommen und dafür
brauchen wir weiterhin maximalen Druck
auf die russische Seite damit sie
überhaupt bereit sind an einfachen
ich ich höre und sehe Widerspruch von
Herrn Keup
ich sehe das natürlich etwas anders also
ich beobachte das ganze ja immer so ein
bisschen aus der Außenperspektive weil
ich ja nicht in Deutschland lebe aber in
Deutschland gibt es ja immer diesen
Spruch nie wieder Krieg so was machen
Sie wenn der Aggressor sich nicht an
diesen Spruch halten will also sie
stellen sich hin Friedensbewegung und
sagen nie wieder Krieg jetzt kommt Putin
sagt interessiert mich nicht ich falle
jetzt in die Ukraine ein was machen sie
jetzt wenn sie das ernst Meinung nicht
wie mit nie wieder Krieg lassen Sie mich
das noch sagen dann müssten sie sich
eigentlich moralisch gesehen auf die
Seite des angegriffenen Stellen also
sprich sicherstellen dass diese Adresse
nie wieder in der Lage ist eine solchen
Angriffskrieg zu führen wenn sie jetzt
sagen man kann über alles verhandeln
auch über die Fragen der Territorialität
dann würde ich sagen bevor solche
Verhandlungen beginnen ist das zunächst
eine Frage der militärischen Lage also
sprich ich glaube das habe ich genau das
habe ich eben gesagt
dann könnten Sie vielleicht sagen gut
wir treten an Teil des Gebietes ab und
und dafür lassen wir euch in Ruhe das
ist aber letztlich das Denken des 19
Jahrhunderts und dem möchte ich wirklich
scharf widersprechen es ist nicht
wirklich getan aber ich habe das an
keinem Grund gesagt an solche Politik
durchzusetzen wo wir sagen
aber ich habe das nicht gesagt
ich habe ganz im Gegenteil gesagt dass
wir maximalen Druck auf die Russische
Föderation aufrecht erhalten müssen weil
wir sonst überhaupt keine Öffnung für
Verhandlungen bekommen
aber auch wenn ich das nicht bin kann
ich schon immer noch argumentieren dass
natürlich Pazifismus immer noch von
Bedeutung ist natürlich müssen wir doch
auch Positionen zulassen die sagen wir
wollen eine Lösung ohne Waffen weil das
uns irritieren sollte es soll uns immer
wieder daran erinnern selbst wenn wir
der Meinung sind und ich stimme ihn
absolut zu noch einmal dass wir
weiterhin auch militärische maximalen
Druck ausüben aber wir müssen uns doch
so weit irritieren lassen sonst immer
wieder daran erinnert aber wir müssen
auch gucken gibt es Öffnungen für
Verhandlung als ich gesagt habe man kann
die territorie entschuldigen Sie bitte
die territoriale Frage nicht komplett
ausschließen was ich damit meinte war
wenn wir überhaupt Verhandlung für
sinnvoll halten dann muss es möglich
sein zunächst einmal dass beide Seiten
prinzipiell bereit sind über irgendwas
zu verhandeln mir geht's auch nicht
darum der der Ukraine irgendwelches Land
wegzunehmen weit gefehlt wenn überhaupt
dann spreche ich darüber dass man
bestimmte territorialstrittige Fragen
die mit diesen
Konfliktparteien momentan nicht zu lösen
sind weil ihre Position diametral
entgegengesetzt sind die eine hat eine
völkerrechtlich nicht vertretbare
Position die andere hat eine
völkerrechtlich völlig legitime Position
aber es ist nun mal diametral
entgegengesetzt und was ich machen kann
zum Beispiel ist zu überlegen ob ich
diese territorialen Fragen offen lasse
und in die Zukunft verlege in die
Zukunft in der dann wieder eine Chance
da ist vielleicht auch vernünftig
miteinander zu geraten aber darüber
brauchen wir glauben jetzt nicht
streiten ich bin auch kein Gegner bin
auch keine Friedens bewegte sondern es
geht mir eigentlich darum ihr die
Differenzen noch mal deutlich zu machen
ich möchte gerne noch eine Stimme eines
Zuschauers mit einbinden Matthias Leib
und gut schreibt wichtig ist was die
Ukraine will Russland muss von der
Ukraine abziehen dann nach muss der
Aufbau angegangen werden es muss zu erst
Zeit vergehen bevor der Aggressor zur
Rechenschaft gezogen wird also da wird
schon sehr weit auch in die Zukunft
geblinkt und ich sehe dass sie dem User
beide zustimmen ich würde gerne noch mal
auf eine Argumentation von Frau
Wagenknecht eingehen inhaltlicher Natur
in der es auch darum geht wer sich denn
wann überhaupt welchen Gesprächen öffnet
oder verweigert und da hören wir mal
gerade rein in einen o Ton von mir
es gab im Frühjahr Friedensgespräche
einmal hat der damalige israelische
Ministerpräsident Bennet welche
vermittelt es gab dann Verhandlungen
Istanbul und die übereinstimmenden
Berichte waren das damals die
Kompromissbereitschaft beiderseiten also
der Ukraine und aber auch der russischen
relativ hoch war und das das von London
und Washington blockiert wurde das heißt
mein Vorwurf ist dass der Westen im
Grunde jetzt ein Jahr lang zwar immer
mehr Waffen liefert aber nichts dafür
tut das Verhandlungen und
Friedensinitiativen irgendeine Chance
haben man muss doch erstmal ein Angebot
machen bevor man Putin dafür kritisieren
kann dass es nicht annimmt
Frau deitelhoff was ist dran an diesem
Vorwurf ja an dem wir sozusagen ein
Fünkchen Wahrheit dran und dann jede
Menge Verschwörungstheorie also stimmt
es gab im Frühjahr diese Verhandlungen
ich glaube nach Karli Bennett hat über
die Shuttle Diplomatie die er damals
betrieben hat im Nachhinein gesagt er
hätte eine 50% Chance gesehen dass es zu
einer Einigung auf ernsthafte
Verhandlung kommt nicht mehr und hat im
Nachhinein auch gesagt na ja und ich bin
mir auch nicht sicher ob es wirklich so
hoch war die USA und Großbritannien
haben das zum damaligen Zeitpunkt glaube
ich anders eingeschätzt sie haben die
Wahrscheinlichkeit eines Gelingens als
viel geringer angesehen und das lag vor
allen Dingen daran dass insgesamt die
Einschätzung war dass man der Russischen
Föderation nicht trauen könnte ganz
kurze Zeit später kam es zu den
sogenannten vertrauensbildenden
Maßnahmen seitens Russland gegenüber der
Ukraine man werde sich aus der Region
Kiew zurückziehen und Vertrauen bei der
Ukraine zu erzeugen was hat man gemacht
und hat sich rekrutiert und hat im Osten
eine neue Offensive begonnen und bei dem
Rückzug sind zugleich dann die
geräueltaten von Gutschein und anderen
Orten sichtbar geworden und damit war
das Thema Verhandlung erledigt und das
lag nicht an der Ukraine das lag auch
nicht an den USA oder an Großbritannien
das LAG letzten Endes am Verhalten der
Russischen Föderation
Herr Kolb dazu direkt und ich verknüpfe
es mit einer Frage wenn man nach dem was
Frau deitelhoff gerade gesagt hat auch
davon ausgehen kann oder muss das Putin
gar nicht verhandeln will muss dieser
Konflikt dann jetzt erstmal auf dem
Schlachtfeld entschieden werden
also ich erlaube mir vielleicht noch
zwei Details im hinzuzufügen also Frau
deutler hat völlig recht mit ihrer
Darstellung einfach dass die Zuschauer
das wissen also der israelische
Außenminister bennet hat auf Youtube ein
sehr langes Interview gegeben über fünf
Stunden und zwar auf Hebräisch und
dieses Interview ist untertitelt worden
auf Englisch und bei diesen Untertiteln
da gibt es ein Übersetzungsfehler ja die
Untertitel sprechen davon dass er
angeblich sagt die Verhandlungen wurden
blockiert das sagte aber gar nicht er
sagt dem Originalton sie wurden gestoppt
er spricht auch nicht über einen
Friedensabkommen sondern er spricht über
Gespräche also er sagt die Gespräche
wurden gestoppt und warum weil man genau
zu dem Zeitpunkt die Kriegsverbrechen
von Botschaft entdeckt hat so und dann
gab es den russischen Propaganda Center
Sputnik der hat das aufgenommen und als
Falschmeldung also alles in ins
verschwörungstheoretischen Sinne
verbreitet und gesagt ja aber die USA
haben quasi darauf hingewirkt dass
angeblich diese Verhandlungen
abgebrochen wurden und dann gab es in
Deutschland gewisse Exponenten wie zum
Beispiel Gregor Gysi oder auch Frau
Wagenknecht die diese Story aufgenommen
und verbreitet haben ob aus Unkenntnis
und Naivität oder ob sie es absichtlich
getan haben das weiß ich nicht aber
diese Story ist definitiv falsch
so und wenn Sie jetzt auf Ihre Frage
abzielen für mich ist die Lage ganz
einfach die Frage nach Verhandlungen
wird zunächst einmal determiniert durch
die militärische Realität auch wenn das
in Deutschland viele nicht wahrhaben
wollen aber die Art und Weise wie ich
verhandle aus welcher Position ich
verhandelt hast ob das eine Position der
Stärke ist oder eine Schwäche die ergibt
sich aus der militärischen Lage das
heißt wenn wir wollen dass die Ukraine
in einer Position ist wo sie tatsächlich
auf Augenhöhe verhandelt kann mit den
Russen dann muss sie in einer Lage sein
wo Sie entweder die russische Aggression
zurückwirft oder zumindest glaubwürdig
damit drohen kann das wäre
frühestmögliche Zeitpunkt wo man
Verhandlungen einsteigen kann und
zusätzlich müssen die Russen dann
erkennen dass es wirklich so ist man
vielleicht in sich Putin in irgendwelche
narrative ein und sagt das kann ja
eigentlich gar nicht sein weil wir sind
ja angeblich die zweitbeste der Welt
diese enzauberung der russischen Armee
die hat ja mittlerweile stattgefunden
vielleicht ist sie ihm noch nicht ganz
klar aber ich denke es ist viel zu früh
darüber jetzt zu sprechen dazu kommt
auch direkt eine Frage an Sie von
Alexander Weber der fragt ob sie glauben
dass die Panzerlieferungen dafür
eventuell zu spät kommen bzw nicht
ausreichend sind
nein die kommen nicht zu spät also Polen
hat zum Beispiel heute offiziell den
ersten panzertransport in die Ukraine
verkündet das heißt die ersten leoparden
sind schon da die Ukraine werden im
Moment ausgebildet sowohl in Polen also
in Deutschland also die die Time Crews
in einem sechswöchigen Kurs der geht
Mitte bis Ende März zu Ende und wenn sie
jetzt zusammenzählen was haben wir
derzeit jetzt schon in der
amerikanischen Logistik an Fahrzeugen
wir haben mindestens 60 Bradleys wiR
haben 100 Mörder wir haben mindestens 30
Leopard wir bekommen zusätzlich per Ende
März 14 britische Challenger da kommen
noch die amerikanischen erbrems dazu das
heißt wir werden per Ende März Anfang
April ein Verband von ungefähr 100
Fahrzeugen haben also sowohl mein better
times also Kampf Panzer als auch
Infanterie fighting vircles also
unterstützungsfahrzeuge wie zum Beispiel
den Bradley m2 und wenn die anfangen mit
ihrer 35 mm autokernen auf sowjetische
T-72 zu schießen dann geht das nicht gut
aus für die T-72 also nein das kommt
nicht zu spät im Gegenteil es kommt
rechtzeitig nämlich für eine ukrainische
Frühjahrsoffensive die ist jetzt
natürlich begrenzt ist klar also sie
können nicht die ganze Front damit
aufräumen aber in einem gewissen
Teilsektor könnten sie damit
durchbrechen ich prognostiziere das
übrigens also für den Sektor zwischen
das ist sicher interessant für viele
Userinnen und User die auch immer sehr
an diesen militärischen Bewegungen und
und militärischen Fragen interessiert
sind ich würde gerne noch mal auf das
Thema Frieden zurückkommen der nicht
gleich Frieden ist das habe ich ja
eingangs gesagt und dazu hat sich
gestern auch der Kanzler geäußert beim
Maybrit Illner und da werden wir auch
kurz rein
ich habe von Anfang an gesagt dass die
Frage was der Inhalt einer Verständigung
zwischen der Ukraine und Russland ist
nicht von uns und von außen ja diktiert
werden kann aber das ist doch
offensichtlich Russland kann nicht
darauf setzen dass es ein Diktat Frieden
durchsetzen kann es kann nicht darauf
setzen dass einfach irgendwie
die Linie wo die Kriegsverlauf
gegenwärtig ist festgefroren wird und
der Rest dann mehr oder weniger
annektiert werden kann sondern es geht
nur in dem Russland versteht dass es
Truppen zurückziehen muss dass wir
tatsächlich eine Verständigung
ermöglichen und das ist das was ich
immer wiederhole übrigens auch in den
vielen vielen Gesprächen die ich mit dem
russischen Präsidenten führe denn wir
sind ja sehr unterschiedlicher Meinung
aber es müssen ja ein paar Leute mal
kommen und ihm auch noch widersprechen
das wird ja in seinem unmittelbaren
Umfeld kaum passieren
feiern ich wollte eigentlich ich wollte
eigentlich Frau deitelhoff fragen
zunächst mal dazu was wir ja daraus auch
lernen ist dass es Gespräche
offensichtlich gibt ähm wenn die
Forderung da ist ihr müsst verhandeln
dann muss man offensichtlich sehen es
wird gesprochen miteinander können Sie
uns da ein bisschen ein bisschen was
drüber erzählen
ja tatsächlich dieses Gespräche finden
die ganze Zeit statt also das sind eben
Telefonate die einzelne
Regierungssprecher bzw eben
Premierminister Bundeskanzler und so
weiter mit dem Kreml mit Putin also
direkt führen aber auch mal zwischen den
Außenministerien oder zwischen
chef-diplomaten und da wird immer wieder
versucht auszuloten inwiefern gibt es
eine Öffnung sehen wir in bestimmten
Bereichen das Positionen aufweichen das
war besonders stark würde ich sagen im
ende letzten Herbst ist da haben wir das
ja deutlich gesehen dass z.B auch die
USA und Russland wieder direkte
Gespräche miteinander geführt haben der
ging es vor allen Dingen darum rote
linienfest zu legen um eine nukleare
eskalationsgefahr zu begrenzen das war
auch durchaus wichtig aber was man eben
nicht geschafft hat ist es tatsächlich
durchzudringen und zu sehen es gibt
tatsächlich mehr als dieses naja wir
versuchen mal irgendwie die nuklearen
Fragen so ein bisschen
untereinander zu klären aber eine große
Öffnung ist nicht da und tatsächlich
würde eben auch sagen die Vorbedingung
damit es überhaupt zu Gesprächen zu
ernsthaften Friedensgesprächen kommen
kann ist tatsächlich dass die russische
Seite ihre Truppen zurückzieht und da
sind wir eben noch lange nicht dafür
muss ich auch noch im Krieg im Konflikt
also auf dem Schlachtfeld auch wenn ich
diesen Begriff nicht besonders schätze
aber dort muss ich noch etwas bewegen
jetzt hatte Herr Kolb ein bisschen
Gelegenheit tief in sein Inneres
sonnenzentrum zu atmen Herr Kolb was
genau hat der Kanzler gerade gesagt was
sie so auf die Palme gebracht hat ja er
hat gesagt also seine seine Antwort also
Putins on Touran sagt ihm offenbar nicht
die ganze Wahrheit und dann habe ich
gedacht na ja also der Bundeskanzler tut
es eigentlich auch nicht wissen also
wenn wenn zwei Dinge in Russland
respektiert werden dann sind das Mut und
Stärke das ist das Einzige was die
Russen wirklich respektieren ich würde
wirklich gewissen Menschen in
Deutschland empfehlen ist sie sollen
doch mal einen Grundkurs machen wie man
mit Russen verhandelt
verstehen sie denn wenn sie hingehen und
sind immer wieder
antraben und sagen lasst uns doch bitte
reden das nimmt kein Russe Ernst das ist
in Russland ein Zeichen von Schwäche
natürlich macht das Sinn dass die
militärischen Generalstäbe miteinander
reden das tun sie auch um eben
Eskalation Superman es gibt ja auch nach
wie vor dass das rote Telefon also wie
damals in kalten Krieg es macht
natürlich auch Sinn dass die Fachbeamten
miteinander sprechen aber solange Putin
das Gefühl hat es gibt noch europäische
Politiker bei denen finde ich gehört und
wenn ich ganz schlimm mit dem selber
Rasse dann kommen die sogar bei mir in
Moskau vorbei solange er dieses Gefühl
hat hatte die den Eindruck er ist noch
nicht vollständig isoliert und solange
das denkt als alter Jack ist und
Deutschland Kenner denkt er super ich
habe ein Hebel ich habe Unterstützer in
Deutschland offenbar ist die Politik
dort nicht hart genug also versuche ich
weiterhin mein Glück
erkannt genau ich wollte nicht dass er
diesen Eindruck von der Regierung haben
kann ich glaube in diesem Gespräch ist
ja immer wieder sehr deutlich gemacht
die Voraussetzung ist dass du deine
Truppen aus dem ukrainischen Gebiet
zurückziehst also ich glaube nicht dass
er da den Eindruck bekommt die Politik
in Deutschland wäre nicht hart genug und
ich glaube insgesamt wenn ich ihr ein
Bild von Russland trauen würde dann
würde ihn das auch nicht besonders
interessieren oder von seinem Kurs
abbringen können und ich würde gerne
noch hinzufügen es ist ja keiner rein
deutsche Position sondern es war der
französische Präsident macron der gesagt
hat wir müssen mit Putin verhandeln weil
die alternativen noch viel schlimmer
werden ja da sehen sie eben das sowohl
Frankreich als auch Deutschland aus
einer langen Tradition der Russland
versteher bzw der Russland
Freundlichkeit kommen ich möchte bitte
betonen dass sie auch das ganze Bild
sehen also wenn sie jetzt schon über
Frankreich reden sprechen Sie doch z.B
auch mal überholen oder über
Großbritannien oder über die baltischen
Staaten das sieht man das ganze nämlich
völlig anders in Spanien übrigens auch
in Italien übrigens auch also sie dürfen
nicht denken dass das was sie in
Deutschland oder Frankreich passiert ist
das stellvertreten sei für Europa das
ist nicht so und das sehen sie vor allem
in narrativ des deutschen Bundeskanzlers
der stellt sich nämlich hin und sagt die
Ukraine darf diesen Krieg nicht
verlieren so was heißt das jetzt konkret
ja das gibt Putin tatsächlich Spielraum
die Briten die Polen die Balken stellen
sich hin und sagen die Ukraine muss
diesen Krieg gewinnen und das ist eine
völlig andere Einstellung und meiner
Ansicht nach die einzig richtige die
nämlich sagt diese Aggression ist
völkerrechtlich nicht zu tolerieren und
muss vollständig rückgängig gemacht
werden das ist der Unterschied den die
Leute begreifen müssen und viele
Politiker in Deutschland haben das
bisher noch nicht realisiert
also hier kann man noch viel über
mögliche Verhandlungen und Optionen
sprechen Frau deitelhoff ich würde gerne
die Runde schließen mit einer Frage an
Sie noch mal gerade weil es in
Deutschland auch so eine große Rolle
spielt vor dem Hintergrund dieser
Friedensdemos deine Userin oder ein User
namens JT fragt wie sollte man mit gut
gemeinten aber substanzlosen
friedensförderungen umgehen ohne eine
Spaltung der Gesellschaft zu riskieren
also ich glaube es geht darum immer
wieder zu erklären was die Voraussetzung
für ein belastbaren Frieden sind und
diese Voraussetzungen sind eben jetzt
nicht gegeben also wer immer fordert
Friedensverhandlungen jetzt warfen
Lieferung stoppen Sanktionen Aufheben
der macht nichts anderes als im Grunde
genommen damit einverstanden zu sein
dass die Ukraine als unabhängiger Staat
aufhört zu existieren wer ein
belastbaren Frieden will der muss Druck
auf die russische Seite aufrecht
erhalten oder sogar verstärken damit
Russland zum Rückzug gezwungen wird und
damit eben auch dazu gezwungen wird sich
Gedanken darüber zu machen wie sie
diesen Konflikt am Verhandlungstisch
beenden können
vielen Dank für diese Einschätzung ich
möchte mich verabschieden von Ihnen
beiden nicht ohne Lob aus der Community
an Sie weiterzugeben hier schreibt Robo
Krabbe diese Gäste sind sehr gut und zum
Abschluss wünscht sich the real Godzilla
über Youtube ich bin für Frieden
zwischen den beiden Experten ich habe
das Gefühl ich kann sie nach dieser
lebhaften Auseinandersetzung nach diesem
lebhaften Austausch der Argumente sehe
ich beide Daumen hoch vielen Dank in
einen friedlichen Abend entlassen und
ich danke Ihnen sehr dass Sie bei uns in
der Sendung waren
Liebe Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer
Frieden für die Ukraine ist noch in
weiter Ferne das ist die bittere
Erkenntnis dieses Jahres Tages nach dem
Einmarsch der Russen in die Ukraine und
leider auch am Ende dieses Streams wir
werden Sie weiter darüber informieren
wir freuen uns mit Ihnen die Meinungen
und Fragen weiter austauschen zu können
danke schön dass ihr und sie dabei wart
tschüss
[Musik]